iran un million et demi de manifestants
aujourd'hui dans les référents mais il
n'y a pas eu d'incident béguines a reçu
le prix nobel de la paix sa date n'était
pas là et de nouvelles négociations se
prépare
célébration oecuménique à notre-dame les
églises entendent participer au combat
des droits de l'homme le tiercé pour
gagner aujourd'hui il fallait jouer dans
l'ordre 17 4 20 bonsoir
une véritable marée humaine dans les
rues de téhéran ce matin plus d'un
million et demi d'iraniens ont défilé à
l'occasion de l'achoura
le point culminant de la période de
deuil des musulmans chiites
manifestation religieuse manifestations
politiques aussi contre le régime du
shah et tout s'est déroulé dans le calme
c'est le deuxième fait marquant de la
journée à téhéran avec le nombre des
manifestants il n'y a eu aucun incident
tout au long de la procession suivie
pour nous par bernard benyamin errants
vient de vivre la plus grande
manifestation que l'iran ait jamais
connu un million de personnes
2 millions mêmes disent les
organisateurs ont défilé dans une
capitale vidé de ses militaires avec un
calme et une dignité tout à fait
impressionnant d'un côté les hommes de
loin les plus nombreux toutes habillées
de noir de l'autre les femmes portant le
tchador le voile noir traditionnel 12
criant sans passion outrancière allah
est grand
gilles la renaissance de la religion
chip vive l'ayatollah khomeini ils ont
démontré de façon éclatante aujourd'hui
que rien ne pouvait se faire en iran
dans les religieux en tête du défilé
karim diaby le leader du front national
littéralement portés par les
manifestants
visiblement satisfait de la tournure des
événements en fait le peuple de téhéran
lui a donné aujourd'hui
l'assise populaire
il avait manqué bien edwards lors cette
grande manifestation de téhéran s'était
en fait une épreuve de force
alors ce soir est ce qu'on peut dire que
quelqu'un a gagné oui je crois que c'est
la première conclusion qu'il faut tirer
de cette journée c'est une victoire une
certaine victoire pour le premier
ministre et pour le gouvernement
militaire
simplement parce qu'il n'y a pas eu
d'incident alors on peut l'expliquer
simplement en regardant cette carte de
la ville de terrain vous avez une grande
avenue qui s'appelle shah reza au sud
vous avez les quartiers populaires les
quartiers pauvres avec le bazar au nord
les quartiers un peu plus riche quartier
résidentiel avec le palais du roi
anja warrants il ya eu huit cortèges qui
sont partis ce matin du sud qui ont
gagné charisa premier point de rencontre
l'université il ya eu les fameuses
émeutes du 5 novembre et ensuite le
point final de la rencontre dans le
calme à shia ne sert que tous les
manifestants ont convergé dupe de la
partie sud de la ville vers cherian pas
bien ça fait grandes avenues shah reza
d'accord et dans tout le sud
ce matin les militaires avaient quitté
le sud de la ville pour se replier dans
le nord il ya donc eu aucun contact
entre les manifestants et l'armée et
donc aucun incident bien l'épreuve de
force je vous disais tout à l'heure mais
il ya eu aussi une démonstration
étonnante impressionnante de la part de
l'opposition tout de même c'est une
victoire incontestable de l'opposition
aussi bien laïque que deux religieuses
chiites savez un million et demi à deux
millions de personnes dans les rues
d'une capitale qui en compte 3 millions
c'est énorme et je crois qu'il faudrait
ce soir pour conclure faire preuve un
peu d'imagination
en regardant cette carte imaginez un
homme seul dans son palais agne avare en
regardant défiler toute la journée
un million et demi d'habitants de
téhéran je crois que comme disent les
iraniens on peut pas prévoir ce qui va
se passer demain en iran mais il faudra
que quelque chose se passe parce que
demain il faut le dire une nouvelle
manifestation est prévue organisée donc
par les musulmans chiites qui doit
normalement emprunter le même parcours
le même parcours à partir du sud jusqu'à
la place shia bien l'ayatollah khomeini
le chef religieux chiite dont le nom a
été acclamé par les manifestants de
téhéran a célébré lui aussi dans sa
maison de neauphle-le-château dans la
région parisienne
l'achoura près de 200 iranien et
quelques cheat libanais ont passé cette
journée de dimanche avec l'ayatollah
dans le parc de sa maison ou une tante
bleus avaient été installés l'ayatollah
comédie n'a fait qu'une brève apparition
pour participer avec ses fidèles à la
prière de midi
et pour commenter les nouvelles qui lui
parvenaient de téhéran vous savez que
les autorités françaises lui ont demandé
de garder une certaine réserve dans ses
propos étant donnée sa condition d'exilé
politique devant près de soixante mille
fidèles réunis place saint pierre pour
l'angélus le pape jean paul ii a demandé
ce matin aux catholiques de prier pour
l'iran de payer également pour le liban
et pour la terre sainte avec regret a
dit le souverain pontife je n'irai pas
sur le mont sinaï où j'ai été invité par
le président sadate aller en
terre-sainte c'était et c'est encore mon
plus grand désir depuis le début de mon
pontificat mais pour le moment je
renonce à ce voyage
le président sadate comme prévu a lui
aussi renoncé un voyage ces derniers
jours il ne s'est pas rendu à oslo en
norvège pour y recevoir le prix nobel
rester en egypte
il a accueilli dès ce soir monsieur
cyrus vance le secrétaire d'état
américain qui entame ainsi une nouvelle
mission de paix au proche orient
l'heure de vérité est arrivée a expliqué
le président sadate
dans le message qu'il a adressé au jury
du prix nobel
le premier ministre israélien monsieur
begin en recevant son prix lui a évoqué
la première capital échangé avec le chef
de l'état égyptien
plus de guerre plus d'effusion de sang
maurice werther et ronge prix nobel de
la paix décerné ce matin à oslo par la
présidente du comité norvégien
madame marcelline as au premier ministre
israélien monsieur b guinée au chef de
l'état égyptien
monsieur sadate l'étrange et peut-être
prématurée parce que la paix n'est pas
encore signé entre israël et l'egypte
est au contraire les obstacles de
dernière minute s'accumulent étrange
cérémonie où l'un des lauréats est
présent monsieur begin
mais l'autre s'est fait représenté par
son conseiller politique monsieur sayed
marei
c'est sans doute pour accueillir
monsieur vence le ministre américain des
affaires étrangères que monsieur sadate
lui est resté hockey et non parce qu'il
eut bouder la cérémonie d'oslo
monsieur vente va essayer de débloquer
la négociation en principe l'accord de
camp david expire le 17 décembre soit
dimanche prochain et il faudra
probablement que monsieur vente tels son
prédécesseur kissinger face la navette
entre le caire et jérusalem pour
convaincre ses interlocuteurs israéliens
et égyptiens
il fera de toute façon un voyage à
jérusalem mardi pour assister aux
funérailles nationales de l'ancien
premier d'une ferrade à mme golda meir
troisième grands titres de l'actualité
en ce dimanche 10 décembre celle le 30e
anniversaire de la proclamation
universelle des droits de l'homme par
les nations unies un anniversaire qui a
été l'occasion comme souvent pour nombre
d'hommes politiques et de chefs d'états
de prononcer des discours pleins
d'espoir il y a eu des paroles quelques
actes aussi des prisonniers libérés à
cuba en mauritanie en iran aujourd'hui
en marge de la grande manifestation à
l'occasion de cet anniversaire
705 prisonniers dont 233 détenus de
droit commun ont été libérés ce matin
selon radio téhéran et puis à londres
une manifestation organisée par amnesty
international avec une immense bougie
allumer une bougie de 175 kilos de cire
de six mètres de haut
une bougie qui symbolise ces droits de
l'homme et qui voudrait bien être
allumée est resté brillante pendant de
nombreuses années
cette bougie a été allumé par la femme
de l'ambassadeur de grande-bretagne à
dublin madame edward meeks ambassadeur
de grande bretagne qui avait été tué il
ya deux ans dans un attentat tandis qu'à
paris une réunion publique était
organisée par amnesty international
également au palais du trocadéro sur ce
même thème des droits de l'homme jean
françois kahn y assister pour nous
l'actualité la plus récente nous a
fourni deux exemples frappants auquel il
a été fait allusion ici
d'une part ce qui s'est passé à pékin
avec un vous le savez on a vu apparaître
des affiches étrange et dans ces
affiches des citoyens chinois
on appelait aux démocraties et ils
disaient vous vous intéressez beaucoup
au pays où règne une oppression raté par
exemple l'union soviétique ou pour un
simple délit d'opinion ou peut être
condamné à 20 ans de prison à régime
sévère mais vous oubliez les pays acp
répression réussi comme ici en chine ou
pour délit d'opinion on peut être
condamné à mort et exécuté
le deuxième exemple se déroule à
santiago du chili au chili
plusieurs centaines de militants de
gauche avait disparu depuis plusieurs
années les autorités disaient qu'elles
ne savaient pas ce qu'ils étaient
devenus or récemment un agent de la
police secrète lors d'une confession a
fait des aveux a un frère
ce prêtre s'est adressé à l'épiscopat
l'épiscopat demandé aux autorités
d'aller creuser quelque part pas loin de
santiago dans une carrière de chaux vive
on a creusé et on vient de découvrir un
charnier avec des dizaines de cadavres
marqué de traces de balles dans la tête
et il semble bien que ce soit ces
militants de gauche qui avait disparu
alors ce sont deux exemples qui nous
montre que oui le bilan est tragique
encore qu'il reste beaucoup à faire et à
dénoncer l'église à sa façon a tenu à
célébrer elle aussi les 30 ans de la
déclaration universelle des droits de
l'homme des cérémonies religieuses
oecuméniques se sont déroulés dans
plusieurs églises en france la
principale réunissant catholiques
protestants et chrétiens orthodoxes a
été célébrée à notre dame de paris cet
après midi philippe harrouard une foule
immense pour cette cérémonie à
notre-dame président est à la fois par
le cardinal marty le pasteur jacques
maury et monseigneur mais l'etios
président des évêques orthodoxes des
chants des textes des témoignages ont
rappelé à tous que l'évangile rejoignait
la déclaration des droits de l'homme et
que chacun était solidaire de la dignité
humaine
cette cérémonie oecuménique qui a été
interrompue un moment par un groupe
d'intégristes avait été organisée à
l'initiative des chrétiens pour
l'abolition de la torture
le message des églises catholiques
orthodoxes et protestantes a été lu par
le pasteur maury il insiste pour que les
chrétiens participent aux combats des
droits de l'homme et que les églises
exercent leur ministère de vigilance
auprès des pouvoirs publics
on est en règle et dont une utilisée
faut parfois qu'aujourd'hui tolérer des
pratiques montrer aux droits de l'homme
et au respect des papilles c'est
pourquoi nous avons un autre porte il
est à nous efforcer toujours davantage
de mettre en pratique les manger dans
notre pays vous longs et attachés aux
libertés fondamentales tout soudain joué
six fois que mme il faudrait que l'on
pense aux étrangers aux travailleurs
immigrés et dans le temps où plus d'un
million de travailleurs connaissent
angoisses du chômage comment oublier
qu'avec la rasion universelle des droits
de l'homme mentionne parmi ces droits
essentiels le droit au travail et la
protection contre
et puis toujours à propos des droits de
l'homme 3000 réfugiés vietnamiens
environ selon les organisateurs ont
manifesté cet après-midi à paris pour un
vietnam libre parmi eux il y avait
plusieurs réfugiés du à hong kong qui
brandissaient une banderole
il n'y a eu aucun incident cours de
cette manifestation vous savez que
depuis quelques semaines nous vous en
avons parlé dans question de temps avec
lui berio un comité essaie de réunir des
fonds pour affréter un bateau
au vietnam pour le vietnam qui re est au
secours des réfugiés qui quittent leur
pays
dans une lettre publiée hier en première
page du figaro monsieur robert hersant
indiqué qu'il n'aidera pas le comité du
bateau pour le vietnam
je ne désire pas mêler mes journaux avec
ceux qui furent les complices des années
durant des agresseurs du sud vietnam
avec ceux qui dénoncèrent les américains
tout le temps où ils se bâtir pour
sauver la liberté des hommes et des
femmes du sud vietnam a dit robert r ça
cette lettre a été adressée à olivier
todd rédacteur en chef de l'express
voici la réaction d'olivier todd après
avoir pris connaissance de la lettre de
robert hersant sens ne surmonte pas
l'homme le mieux placé de france pour
reprocher aux autres
dans opinion passé en pratique je
constate qu'ils refusent de s'associer à
une opération humanitaire fort bien
c'est son droit mais là plus loin ils la
dénoncent et alors là je constate qu'il
rejoint par exemple rené andrieu dans
l'humanité qui dénonce également la
campagne pour le vietnam en france
aujourd'hui un homme de droite musclée
ressemble très souvent un stalinien
intégristes pourquoi votre avis est-il
personnellement adressé à vous et non à
la présidente du comité du bâton pour la
vie et accident il se trouve que nous
avons d'abord travaillé dans ce comité
de façon artisanale puis nous avons
demandé aux grands moyens d'information
leur concours puisqu'il s'agissait d'une
oeuvre humanitaire et il se trouve que
moi j'ai téléphoné à une collaboratrice
de robert hersant il ya quelques jours
avez vous reçu beaucoup de soutien
jusqu'à présent énormément c'est assez
extraordinaire pour le moment il ya 65
millions de francs anciens le dernier
chèque étant un cheikh des syndicats
japonais dès qu'ils viennent tous ses
soutiens de genres très variés de toutes
les catégories sociales les chefs vont
de 5 francs
5000 francs et surtout je crois que les
chats qui viennent de gens qui ont des
opinions politique extraordinairement
différentes les uns et les autres
alors aujourd'hui nous constatons que
d'un côté les hommes de droite qui
n'oublie rien comme monsieur versants et
certains hommes de gauche des
communistes ce qui est aussi n'oubliez
rien sont contre cette campagne tempe il
se fera quand même problème des droits
de l'homme enfin avec un incident en
pologne où un journaliste de la
rédaction d'information ouvrière
d'inspiration trotskiste a été
appréhendé mercredi dernier quelques
jours après avoir rencontré des
opposants au régime polonais le syndicat
force ouvrière des journalistes exige
lui aussi la libération immédiate de
philippe trias à l'étranger toujours au
venezuela proclamation officielle des
résultats des dernières élections
présidentielles
aujourd'hui le démocrate-chrétien luis
herrera camping a été confirmé dans ses
fonctions de nouveau président philippe
chatenet et pierre moscovitch qui
reviennent du venezuela où ils ont
d'ailleurs rencontré le nouveau
président ont pu se rendre compte des
contrastes de ce pays le plus riche
d'amérique latine mais qui a aussi comme
tous les autres ces bidonvilles pays le
plus riche d'amérique latine le
venezuela s'est offert une capitale à
l'image de sony
caracas est une machine urbaine en folie
qui engloutit des pétrodollars et
recrache du béton une ville qui détruit
son passé et se renouvelle sans cesse
une ville presque sans trottoirs ou le
chemin obligatoire d'un point à un autre
est une autoroute
la grosse américaine règne sur caracas
après tout le litre du super ici ne
coûte que 30 centimes en une génération
la population de caracas est passé de
200 mille habitants à 3 millions tout le
problème est là car les pauvres du
venezuela rural attirés par les lumières
de la ville viennent s'entasser dans
l'autre caracas celle des bidonvilles un
million de personnes le tiers de la
population vit dans ses rangs de shit os
ou trop souvent il n'y a ni eau potable
ni électricité ni égouts
chaque jour 350 tonnes d'excréments
humains sont déposées dans les rues
ici 60 % des enfants sont illégitimes la
moitié des habitants et sans travail et
pourtant attiré par le rêve de l'argent
facile cent mille campagnard parents
affluent dans les rangs de shit hausse
il suffit de trouver un bout de terrain
libre quelques planches et on s'installe
pour attendre ce n'est pas la politique
qui nous aidera à sortir d'ici ici on ne
gagne rien alors il faut se débrouiller
dans la rue moi j'ai l'espoir de m'en
sortir
l'espoir que ça change pour qu'on puisse
manger à notre faim
nous sommes douze dans cette maison nous
gagnons 400 francs par semaine ce n'est
pas assez parce que tout est très cher
il nous faut un président qui s'occupe
des pots de veiller à ce qu on ne meurt
pas de faim si certains ont du travail
beaucoup d'autres n'en n'ont pas et cela
ne peuvent pas vivre
périodiquement pour les élections on re
découvre ce réservoir de misère mais
aussi de vote
diego arria ancien ministre ancien
gouverneur de caracas candidat
malheureux aux présidentielles il ya
quelques jours a fait l'essentiel de sa
campagne dans les rangs chip un thème
précis le venezuela est ébloui par la
manne pétrolière
on ne rêve que d'industrialisation et
pendant ce temps la différence entre
riches et pauvres ne cesse de croître
nous avons des millions de vénézuéliens
qui ont fui la campagne la ville est
pleine de paysans déracinés on ne se
préoccupe pas assez du problème du
logement est un problème fondamental
pour la dignité humaine
au venezuela le logement est devenu le
problème le plus dramatique d'une
société relativement riche et qui offre
des contrastes aussi violent
l'autre grand problème ici ce sont les
services publics le manque d'eau potable
des goûts et le problème de la sécurité
personnelle
la fierté de diego arria c'est d'avoir
transformé ce quartier de la vega on a
donné aux habitants l'argent et l'aide
technique pour qu'il réhabilite eux
mêmes leur bile on vit l'expérience bien
que réussie n'a pas été poursuivi et à
quelques mètres de là on retrouve la
misère je n'ai rien mais comment vous
vivez avec le peu que je gagne plus ou
moins 50 à 60 francs je leur donne à
manger ici si l'on n'a pas d'argent on
ne peut pas vivre si l'argent et tout
celui qui n'en a pas meurent de faim
j'ai huit gains quand j'ai de l'argent
ils mangent quand je n'en ai pas
qu'est-ce que je peux faire
pourtant la misère au venezuela n'exclut
jamais l'espoir le pays est si riche
il y a toujours les miettes du festin en
attendant vivre dans les rangs quitos
s'est campé aux portes d'un emploi d'un
hôpital d'une école d'une vraie maison
avec l'espoir un jour de descendre dans
la ville des riches il faut accroître
les pouvoirs de l'assemblée européenne
c'est monsieur gaston thorn le premier
ministre du luxembourg qui vient de le
déclarer au club de la presse d'europe 1
contrairement à ce que craignent jacques
chirac et michel debré dit monsieur
thorn
j'estime que la future assemblée risque
de ne pas être trop européenne
les élus cherchant surtout à défendre
leurs intérêts nationaux
arrivé en france demain après-midi du
roi hussein de jordanie qui rencontrera
monsieur valéry giscard d'estaing départ
ce soir pour la corse de monsieur
raymond barre le premier ministre doit
vérifier sur place
l'application des mesures décidées il y
a 6 mois pendant la visite du chef de
l'état dans l'île de beauté
les bureaux de votes sont clos à nice
depuis une vingtaine de minutes pour le
premier tour de l'élection municipale
partielle
troisième secteur évidemment je n'ai pas
encore de résultats pour l'instant mais
je pense qu'avec claude dans son dernier
journal vers 22h40 pourra vous en dire
davantage et puis fin dans la soirée à
vitry dans le val-de-marne de la grande
réunion entre le bureau politique du
parti communiste et ses intellectuels
communistes georges marchais ce a
souligné georges marchais a souligné que
pour avancer la discussion dans le parti
est indispensable mais qu en toutes
circonstances le parti devait conserver
la maîtrise du débat nécessaire en son
sein la réforme de la sécurité sociale
vous savez que des décisions seront
prises mercredi prochain en conseil des
ministres d'ores et déjà le patronat
demande que cette réforme ne se fasse
pas au dépens des entreprises
et puis sur votre agenda de télévision
n'était bien demain soir à 21h30 cartes
sur table avec monsieur rené monory sur
antenne 2 bien sûr l'espace maintenant
succès américain avec l'arrivée sur
venus de quatre secondes qui
transmettent déjà des renseignements aux
scientifiques de la nasa
philippe duez cela fait donc plusieurs
fois que l'on cherche à percer le
mystère de vénus pourquoi venus parce
que c'est une planète presque identique
à la terre mais elle est simplement plus
près du soleil
l'exploit des américains tient à la
précision du tir mais aussi au fait que
les sondes ont mieux résisté que prévu à
l'atmosphère terrible de la planète
vénus
l'une d'elles a même pu continuer à
collecter des informations une fois
arrivé sur le sol et ce pendant plus
d'une heure
l'atmosphère de vénus est en grande
partie du gaz carbonique avec un peu
d'acide sulfurique dans chacune des
quatre sonde américaine se trouvent deux
expériences françaises qui concerne
justement l'atmosphère vénusienne
l'étude des composants des nuages et le
bilan des radiations solaires sur la
planète les premiers résultats sont en
train d'arriver
mais on sait déjà qu'à 40 km d'altitude
la température est encore 200 16 degrés
centigrades
lorsque toutes les données transmises
par les sondes seront analysés les
scientifiques pourront mieux comprendre
la formation des planètes du système
solaire plus donc l'histoire de notre
propre terre et son évolution
c'est finalement une expérience qui nous
concerne de très près la page des sports
maintenant avec tout d'abord la
transatlantique française en solitaire
et des nouvelles de l'un des deux
disparus jacques pallas est il est
arrivé en guadeloupe
cet après midi en revanche toujours
aucune nouvelle du manureva le trimaran
d'alain colas gilles cozanet a interrogé
son frère jean-françois sur ce retard de
plus en plus inquiétants du navigateur
sakho là depuis ce matin la marine
nationale a réduit le nombre de breguet
chargé des recherches de quatre départs
il n'y en a plus qu'un ca veut-il dire
qu'il n'y a plus d'espoir ou que les
recherches ont peut être été entreprise
trop tard plus l'espoir est trop tard je
pense que c'est aller vite en besogne
que les recherches ont été faites par
les brigades la nacion lui briguer la
marine nationale sur une route logique
sur la route logique d'un bateau
naviguant à faible allure sur une route
directe entre les açores et pointe à
pitre on n'a plus de nouvelles d'alain
depuis le 16 mai depuis le 16
si allah n'est pas sur cette zone que
les breguet chercher une zone énorme en
kilomètres carrés et quand on se trouve
ici à terre mais quand on regarde sur la
séance et c'est très étroit depuis le 16
audrey des courants gré des vents il a
fait du chemin chaque jour il fait de la
route et c'est route par le nombre de
jours qui dont on est sans nouvelles
elles deviennent plus en plus grande
il peut très bien se trouver ici ou là
en partant du dernier point notre père
disait que anna n'aurait pas dû prendre
le départ parce que disait-il il n'a
plus rien à prouver ce qu'ils amènent à
se demander si elle n est pas parti avec
un espoir de revanche qui l'a amené à
prendre des risques et que son bateau ni
ni lui n'était en mesure d'assumer
on prend au départ d'une course il y a
des gens qui partent pour participer
d'autres pour gagner il est certain
qu'elle a est un gagneur il n'était pas
le seul dans cette course est gagneur un
la preuve malinoski bear qui sont
également des gens qui ont le même
tempérament et de toute façon quand on
part en solitaire ont fait au départ on
assume un certain risque mais on les
minimise ces risques on part avec un
matériel qui est révisée dont on soit
sûr ce qui est le cas de menou rêvant au
cas où vous n'auriez pas a suivi stade 2
voici maintenant les autres principaux
résultats sportifs de la journée avec en
football d'abord sur un panneau voici
les résultats de la journée donc que
jacques reste balle si vous voulez bien
me les donner voilà merci oui il y avait
six matchs cet après-midi alors a
remarqué le match nul de strasbourg 2 à
2 face à reims le match nul de
saint-etienne et nancy 1 partout le
match nul également de monaco et sochaux
en revanche la victoire de bordeaux au
parc des princes 5 à 2 contre le paris
saint-germain donc au classement
strasbourg est toujours en tête avec 31
points devant nantes saint-etienne et
monaco
à noter quand même que strasbourg un
match en retard devant sochaux en jeu à
xiii l'équipe de france a réédité
l'exploit de carcassonne en battant
l'australie 11 à 10 cet après-midi en
ski le canadien ken read a gagné en
autriche la première descente masculine
de la saison tandis qu'une américaine
fbi fischer a gagné le slalom spécial de
pian de cavallo comptant pour la coupe
du monde
un centième de seconde seulement d'
avance sur perrine pellen qui est
deuxième qu'il y avait un tir c'est
également cet après midi à qui se
disputait à auteuil le prix georges
courtois à la 5e course voici c'est
montcourt leucate qui a gagné devant le
nouvion le vin non c'est en fait c'est
relié en m17 qui a gagné pardon je
répète il faut être très clair pour le
tiercé c'est relié en est le 17 qui a
gagné devant mon cours le 4 et le
nouvion le vin voilà la combinaison
gagnante merci 17,4 et 20 qui rapporte
donc dans l'ordre pour 5 francs 26 1345
francs et dans un ordre différent 5269
francs 17 4 et 20 je répète une fois de
plus pour enduire personne en erreur
je dois vous parler de cheval encore ou
plutôt de poney maintenant car anne
laure c'est le prénom d'une toute petite
fille vous allez le voir ne montre que
sur des poneys
lorsqu elle dispute un concours de
jumping son poney s'appelle hercules
mais pau anne laure guider son compagnon
c'est un véritable jeu d'enfant
regardez ce reportage de pierrette brès
je suis pas un petit peu peur de monter
un concours au sort du fan
siffler
et tu vas tout de même le faire
avec l poney tu vas monter enfants pour
vous
il a pas l'air facile et recul du dow
enfin que j'aurais fait des choix qui
rentrait non pas contre et vincent pas
la queue de l'om et ben mais reculer la
faim tu es tu penses que ton pince sans
rire tellement tellement guitare moi
j'étais vite voir maman aux 1/4 est
partagée peureux à maman mais pas par
quand j'étais un casse parce que sinon
ils sont bien se poser est qu'est ce que
tu sens avec les championnats de france
anne laure sera la plus jeune cavalière
de france dans le concours hippique elle
montrera mercredi prochain
car elle devra se mesurer à des enfants
de 12 ans mais pour elle ce hôtel
auxerre la double barre où le mur en
pierre avec hercules ce n'est qu'un jeu
d'enfant
tu sais quel est le concours que tu vas
monter très vite
c'est une épreuve de puissance bon si ça
veut dire qu'il va falloir sauter très
haut
vous voyez il ya un impact allait voir
oui et e.on et des détails très bas prix
et tu crois que tu peux le faire avec
tamponnais recul mais dis moi tu vas pas
voir un petit problème est ce que tu
sais lire tu vas savoir lire les numéros
sur les obstacles
sienne lors ignore la peur et semble si
sûre d'elle à cheval c'est parce qu
avant même de savoir mot t elle a
compris qu'il fallait surtout échanger
des liens de confiance et d'amitié avec
son poney alnor et accule belle histoire
la météo maintenant pour demain les
prévisions météo pour demain et bien il
y aura de la pluie cela va commencer par
l'ouest ensuite ça va gagner les
flandres l'alsace la lorraine le massif
central et les alpes
en fait les pluies seront beaucoup plus
nombreux sur le quart nord-ouest de la
france sur le pourtour méditerranéen il
y aura des éclaircies plus nombreuses et
les températures en hausse
le vent de sud ouest restera fort sur
les côtes de l'atlantique et de la
manche il sera modéré ailleurs vous
allez retrouver hervé claude vers 22h40
2 pour la dernière édition du journal
d'antenne 2 je vous souhaite une très
belle soirée sur un tender